okay hi everyone
back for another episode of science and
technology q
a for kids and others i have fun with
these things hope you find them
interesting
all right we have a few questions that
were left over from last
week um
so there's a question from brian here
why does mata and antimatter annihilate
when they come together
um what is the mechanism behind an
electron and a positron
converting to energy when they meet
saying the opposite charges doesn't
really explain it
okay so first of all
so things we're usually familiar with
are all
matter that's what atoms and things like
that
that we have around here in the universe
are but there's also this notion of
antimatter
which is a form of matter
where essentially every particle is
replaced by an antiparticle
and so for example just like ordinary
atoms have protons and neutrons in the
nucleus and electrons sort of
outside the nucleus anti-atoms
have anti-protons and anti-neutrons in
the nucleus and anti-electrons
outside and those are anti-electrons are
positrons
so most particles we're familiar with
the anti-particle is a different
particle from the particle itself
one exception to that of photons
particles of light
where the antiphoton is the same as the
photon there's so there's just the
photon there's no antiphoton
particle reason for that is because
photons don't have an electric charge
okay so what is the meaning of this idea
of an anti-particle
so the the first one that was discovered
was the anti-electron the positron
was discovered in the 1930s um
and um the uh okay so what is an
anti-particle
an antiparticle is something just like
an electron
it's it's identical to an electron but
for one change
which is that its electric charge
is the negative of the electric charge
of an electron
so an electron uh due to a bit of a
mistake in very early work that was done
in 1897 or so
is viewed as having charge minus one
maybe in a perfect world
the electron which is so common would
have been viewed as having charge plus
one
but anyway the way that the the way that
the experiments worked out
people assigned charge minus one to the
electron
so uh a chap called pulderak
predicted from the mathematical theory
of this thing called the rak equation
in the 1930s that there should exist
anti-particles of the electron
things just like the electron but with
opposite charge
and uh that's really all there is to say
about positrons they're things just like
electrons
but with opposite charge now when it
comes to
um uh anti-atoms for example
that's a whole interesting issue so back
a long time ago
nobody really knew how much matter
versus antimatter there was in the
universe
people kind of assumed that there was
about as much antimatter in the universe
as matter in the universe
and even even 40 years ago people were
thinking maybe the andromeda galaxy is
made of antimatter that's the nearest
big galaxy to us
um other than our own um and uh you know
how would we even know
if the next door galaxy was made of
antimatter rather than made of ordinary
matter
well it turned out there's pretty good
evidence that almost
everything we see in the universe is is
mata not antimatter
and that's actually a bit of a
surprising thing because usually
things tend to be symmetrical and you'd
expect that there's mata there's also
antimatter
um but actually almost everything we see
is matter
and there are some theories for why that
might be the case i was even involved in
making some of those up in the
around 1980 or so um the um
uh let's not talk about exactly how
those theories work they're a little bit
complicated
and it's not completely clear yet that
they're correct
but the um you might ask do we have
anti-atoms at all
do we have have we um people have made
anti-atoms
so people have made anti-hydrogen for
example um an
anti-proton with a positron um and um
you can um it's it's not so easy to make
them because
the way you have to make an antiproton
is by essentially creating a proton
antiproton pair
from essentially pure energy you
create a proton antiproton pair then you
kind of use magnetic fields and things
to pull the antiproton off in a
different direction
from the proton then you let that
antiproton combine with a positron and
then you have
a piece of antihydrogen um
now so one of the questions is what
happens
when if you take an electron and
you uh and it collides with a positron
what happens well
okay so first question is what happens
if you take two electrons
and collide them into each other well
the answer is
that they're both electrically charged
so these two electrons will come
together
and basically the two electrons will
bounce off each other
and they'll they'll be repelled because
they have the same charge they'll bounce
off
and they'll sort of go on their merry
way in a different direction
now in truth that process is a bit more
complicated than that
and for example these two electrons if
they have high enough energy
they can actually when they collide they
can produce photons as well
they could produce many photons actually
um when they
collide and that process of how
the interaction between for example
electrons and photons
there's this whole theory called quantum
electrodynamics which was um kind of
pretty much
done in the 1940s um
which tells one using quantum field
theory
tells one with remarkable accuracy to
work out
the interactions between things like
electrons and things like photons
and so quantum electrodynamics allows
you to compute
the scattering of electrons by electrons
for example
electron electron scattering and and
that's been measured
in great detail whether its predictions
are correct and tells one for example if
two electrons crash into each other
straight on
there'll be a certain uh probability
that they will go off at a different
angle
and what the probability is for
different angles and so on is all worked
out
and what the probability that they
produce one photon two photons and so on
of certain energies is all carefully
worked out
so basically you you crash particles
into each other
and um something will happen okay
well you take different kinds of
particles you crash them into each other
electrons well before our
current new fundamental theory of
physics it seemed like electrons
were just point particles that had no
constituents inside them so
you can't you can't like break an
electron apart
if you take protons for example you
crash two protons into each other
protons are big fluffy particles well
big by some standards
and they contain quarks and gluons and
so on and when you crash two protons
into each other um
quite sometimes the corks inside them
will actually hit each other sometimes
the quarks will miss and
you'll you know the cork will one cork
from one proton will hit gluons and the
other proton and so on but you get a big
mess of stuff
and so as you when you make more and
more energetic protons crash into each
other
they uh proton proton collisions
will produce a whole cascade of
particles
so the highest energies people crash
protons into each other
um in the units that are used a few uh
trillions of electron volts um that's an
energy it's very small compared to
energies that we're familiar with in the
everyday world but these are just tiny
particles that are crashing into each
other
so you crash two protons into each other
at uh the sort of highest energies that
we can do
with with particle accelerators on the
earth get somewhat higher energies from
cosmic rays
um but uh with with particles on the
earth
with particle accelerators on the earth
the highest energies crash into each
other
and you'll typically get when the two
protons hit you'll get a cascade of 300
particles coming out
so or it's like the protons are
shattered and all kinds of junk comes
out
now you um and so what what what does
come out it's a bunch of pions
which are uh cork anti-cork uh particles
made of quarks and antiquarks
protons contain three quarks um you
might get um
i don't know you might get all kinds of
stuff at the highest energies
you could get top quarks you get all
kinds of things made
when protons collide with each other
okay
so uh that's what happens when protons
and protons collide okay what
happens when a proton when an electron
and a positron collide
okay well one one thing to understand is
okay when an electron when two electrons
collide
there is this notion of an electron
number there is a certain
amount of electron-ness that is
is there and that electron this is
conserved and the only way you can kind
of
um so when you have two electrons coming
in you've got to have two electrons
coming out
there's no because that's you've got two
units of electron this
and you end up always having to have two
units of electrons coming out as well
but positrons have like minus one unit
of electronics so when you collide an
electron or positron
you don't have to get any electron-like
thing coming out
the electron or the positron can just
annihilate
and leave no electron-like thing over so
what do they leave over
so the only thing that they have really
the only other kind of particle that
is sort of available is photons so
when an electron and positron collide
the
the um at least at low energies if you
don't if you smash them into each other
really hard i'll tell you what happens
in that case too
but if you just let them just meander
next to each other and they just uh
you know they go they'll actually make
this is a really weird thing they'll
make
an atom called positronium so
positronium is an atom so ordinary
hydrogen for example
has a proton in the center of an
electron going around the outside
you can make this kind of pseudo atom
called positronium
which is uh a um which has a positron in
the center acting like the proton
and an electron going around it well
actually they go around each other
because they're the same mass but
but roughly it's like the the nucleus of
positronium is just a positron
an anti-electron and then you have an
electron combined with it
okay so what happens so so that's
you know you have two electron or
positron they just get close because
they have opposite electric charge they
will attract each other
they might you know go into orbit around
each other and make sort of positonium
but fundamentally they're going to be
pulled together and
what's going to happen to them well
they're going to annihilate because
there's no electronics left over so they
can just turn into
something that has no electrons and and
the thing they get to turn into
because they have to turn into some so
electrons have a certain mass
uh 0.51 million electron volts
um very small mass 10 to the minus
26 kilograms i think
um the uh uh
i think so um anyways
no no no that's i'm sorry 10 to the
minus 29 kilograms
um the uh uh electron is about um
uh one eighteen hundredth the mass of a
proton
uh it's very very light compared to a
proton but anyway
the the electron has some mass and so
the um uh when electron or positron
uh annihilate they even if they
are not moving at any speed that that
the energy associated with that rest
mass has to go somewhere it has to go
into whatever the output is
and the output certainly can't be
something that has a higher mass than
the electron
or it it that's that's not this that's
not a possible thing
so what happens instead is the only
thing that's sort of available
as an annihilation product from electron
depositron
is photons and so the most common thing
that happens when
electron and positron uh annihilate
not going at a very high speed just sort
of meandering next to each other
is they turn into two photons so in
in the official language of quantum
electrodynamics you would say e plus e
minus
e plus is the positron e minus is the
electron
goes to and then a photon is represented
as a
lowercase greek gamma which looks like
kind of a y so e plus e minus goes to
gamma gamma
is the kind of uh the most common
process
um electron positron annihilation to two
photons
so what happens when that so
okay so in sort of a fundamental
feature of of um uh of energy and mass
and so on is
the equals mc squared formula which
tells you that
the rest mass m multiplied by the speed
of light squared
is the energy of a thing so when
electron
positron annihilate two photons which
have zero mass
but they still have an energy what what
happens is
when electron positron annihilate two
photons
you get those two photons each have an
energy that corresponds to the rest mass
of one electron
so so that's that's what happens that's
the most common thing to happen now
sometimes electron positron annihilation
goes to three photons or even four
photons
the chance that you get a larger number
of photons
decreases roughly like a thing called
the fine structure constant
so it's roughly um it's roughly well
that's one over 137 but it's actually
usually that of a pi
so it's usually about one five
hundredths the chance that you get
three photons is one five hundredth the
chance you get two photons
chance you've got four photons there's
one 500th of that again
but so the most common thing that
happens is electron positron annihilate
they produce
uh uh two photons okay that's what
happens if they're just at rest
if electrons and positrons are
annihilated very high speed
then they have more energy and they can
produce more stuff they don't just have
to produce photons they can produce
other particles in fact
many experiments for example a thing
called lep with a large electron
positron machine
um was uh uh sort of a famous particle
accelerator at cern
um in near geneva switzerland um there's
a big uh
i don't know how much 10 mile diameter
type
thing that some accelerates particles
and here's a tricky thing
if you have an accelerator that's using
magnetic fields and it's a circular
accelerator so
it you have an accelerator that uses
magnetic fields to accelerate electrons
the the way it works the electrons will
be accelerating in a certain direction
by the magnetic field
positrons because they have negative
charge relative they have
the negative of the charge of the
electron are actually also accelerated
by the exact same magnetic fields but
they go in the opposite direction
so that's very convenient because you
can have these colliding beams so you've
got
an electron beam circulating one way a
positron beam circulating the other
and you typically have a few crossover
points where
like at every they're usually bunches of
electrons and and
positrons maybe a trillion of them in
each bunch and
every uh every second or something as
the things go around the ring
or every every microsecond maybe as
things go around the ring
these these bunches will cross over and
then when they cross over there's a
certain chance that the electrons and
positrons will interact
and so that's been something that's been
possible to do for really very high
energy electrons and positrons
so the question is what happens when you
collide a high energy electron and a
high energy positron
and the answer is uh you get all kinds
of stuff again
um not because like protons it's not
like the thing sort of shatters like a
proton does
but instead it's just the energy
associated with the
with the electron and positron um they
from that energy you can produce more
particles how does that work
so as i said i and i'm kind of what i'm
kind of doing here is
is giving you a an approximate version
of what you might learn
in a graduate school class about
particle physics
um so and i'm trying to uh i'm trying to
not
um not talk about some of the more
elaborate mathematical aspects of this
but
you can kind of get the main point i
hope from this so when electron positron
annihilate
at rest with no kind of energy crashing
them together
the only thing they can do really is
produce photons and they'll typically
produce
as i mentioned two photons when you
crash them together at very high energy
they can produce other things okay how
does that work
well one feature of physics is
that things tend to be reversible if if
you can go
from one state to another from a to b
then you can usually go from b to a now
at the scale that we see the physical
world that doesn't tend to be how the
way things work
um when we you know break an egg we
see eggs break but we don't see a lot of
eggs spontaneously form themselves from
broken eggs to non-broken eggs
that's a different phenomenon in fact
i'll maybe talk about that in
a few minutes um but uh at a microscopic
level at the level of atoms at the level
of particles electrons things like that
physics is basically reversible anything
if you see a movie
of things you know particles crashing
into each other and producing other
particles you could
as well be seeing a movie in reverse
both of them are valid sort of physical
processes to go on
so i mentioned that electrons and
positrons can annihilate to produce
pairs of photons well that might suggest
to you
that you can reverse that process you
can take pairs of photons
collide them together and get electrons
and positrons out
and indeed that absolutely happens you
can have um
uh that is a process that can occur it's
been observed
it's light by light well it's actually
it's kind of a weird thing because you
essentially are taking two beams of
light except they're not really light
they're
higher energy photons usually gamma rays
and so on high energy photons even even
and you collide these high energy
photons together and
the energy of those photons is converted
into electron and a positron
so this is a feature of the e equals m c
squared story
that you can convert between energy like
the energy of motion kinetic energy
and rest mass of particles so
from photons you can get electrons
and in fact the um um
what happens in boy i am i am
descending rapidly into sophisticated
quantum field theory in particle physics
but let me let me try and explain this
in an electron positron interaction at
high energy
um you uh
i mentioned that when electrons and
positrons just come together
at low energy they can produce pairs of
photons
at high energy well anywhere
they can produce um normally if you just
have a free
electron free positron they annihilate
they produce two photons
there is a sense in which they can
produce a single virtual photon but it
doesn't last very long
and that's kind of what happens in
electron positron annihilation
at high energies is you produce the
single virtual photon
and the single virtual photon can then
turn into a pair of other particles
so for example you might have electron
positron they annihilate
they turn into this virtual photon i'm
not really explaining exactly what that
is
but it's basically it's it's a it's a
kind of a
short-lived thing that's like a photon
that arises in quantum field theory
and that short-lived thing quickly
converts
into let's say an electron positron pair
or a cork antiquark pair or any
particle anti-particle pair basically
and you can think about that photon as
being like
a piece of pure energy it's a photon
i mean anything can have energy but
photons have energy but no rest mass
so you can think about it as pure energy
without mass so
this photon is then going to convert and
it can convert into
a pair of any particle anti-particle
pair
so pick any kind of particle pick your
favorite time particle like a top quark
it could convert if it has enough energy
it can convert into a top court anti-top
cork pair
and in fact that was how the top quark
was discovered
was um uh by seeing that being produced
from electron positron collision
and um the um so in other words what
happens
electron positron collision happens it
basically produces pure energy which
doesn't last very long
and that pure energy then materializes
into particle antiparticle pairs
so particle antiparticle annihilates
to quotes pure energy in the sense of
photons
um or when you know this electron
positron if they if they have a decent
amount of energy
they when they annihilate they can
actually produce not just
photons but also all sorts of of
particle pairs and so on in addition to
just photons
so in a typical electron positron event
collision at the highest energies today
i'm i'm guessing
there are on the order of 100 particles
produced
and these particles usually form these
jets that go off in
specific directions that are along
usually what happens is the original
thing that's formed is a quark anti-cork
pair for example
and but these quarks uh they kind of
that
there are no free quarks quarks are
always
uh confined inside particles like
protons
pions and so on and so the quarks go
outwards and as they go outwards
they're kind of being pulled back
together because
there's this sort of process there's
gluons that try and
confine them into into particles and
that effort to pull them back together
they have so much energy going out that
as the that that sort of glue-on
field tries to pull them back together
it too will start materializing particle
anti-particle pairs
and so you'll get this whole cascade of
particles produced which will
form a jet where you can actually see um
you see all these particles going off in
about the same direction
and long ago when i was a kid actually i
invented some methods for understanding
how
um how the structure of these jets work
and i think those methods are still used
in in particle physics experiments today
which is kind of fun
um all right so that's that's that's a
a rough story of um uh
um of uh of of how
uh uh mata antimatter annihilation works
so basically the point is um
mata and antimatter can turn it can
annihilate to photons
or it can annihilate to any particle
antiparticle pairs
um and uh uh that's
that's how it works and um
i can go into many more details but
actually i'm
i'm pleased that we managed to uh uh
get through that that discussion without
me having to talk about
um a bunch of features of quantum field
theory that
um uh are usually explained only in
mathematical terms
all right let's see there's another
question here
um about uh
our historical understanding of entropy
okay so what is entropy
entropy is a kind of a measure of the
disorder of things
so if we look at you know when we have a
box of gas like box of air
we've got trillions and trillions of
molecules of
of air um nitrogen oxygen whatever
in that box and they're all bouncing
around randomly
all over the place they all seem to be
you know doing things completely
randomly
what we'd like to kind of get a sense of
is how random is that process
and in particular that process of them
bouncing around randomly
that bouncing around randomly is what we
usually think of as heat
what is heat when you heat a material up
what it means is that the atoms
molecules in it
are just bouncing around more and more
when the thing is very cold the atoms
are going very slowly they're very much
they're very fixed in place as you heat
it up they're kind of randomly bouncing
around
now back in the 1800s it was extremely
unclear what
heat was and whether heat was kind of
like a fluid like water that just sort
of
uh sort of got into materials and so it
was sort of caloric
fluid and things like this um flagiston
was a was a name that was sometimes used
for that
fluid that is heat and people were very
confused about what heat was and whether
heat is something
that you can abstractly have heat
independent of
a material object so entropy was
was kind of the thing that was invented
to in a sense represent the
abstract presence of heat without
talking about
the material object that carries the
heat
so when we heat up a bar of metal or
something
what's happening is as we put more if we
increase the temperature
it means the the atoms and the metal are
running around more and more quickly
and um but we can say well what's what
is the abstract thing that's happening
in that bar of metal
that represents the presence of heat
well it's that there's this random
motion of molecules
random motion of atoms and it's this
kind of characterization of the
randomness
that is the notion of entropy
now one of the things that it was a big
observation
particularly in the 1860s and so on was
the question of
uh if you wanted to make a steam engine
or something to what extent could you
turn
heat into mechanical work
to what extent as we would understand it
today
it's to what extent can you take this
random notion of molecules on a very
small scale
and use that to move a big bar of metal
or something
right how can you convert random heat
into large scale motion
okay and and there's a lot of kind of
theory
about the way that heat engines work and
so on that all has to do with and sold
sort of
fundamental results and thermodynamics
having to do with the extent to which
you can turn
sort of random motion into organized
organized motion and and that was kind
of the
the the sort of a version of the way
that entropy arose
was in thinking about that trade-off
between you've got just heat
and then you've got organized mechanical
motion
well there's this kind of a long story
of how entropy works
um the a lot of confusion in the 1800s
1860s 1880s lots of confusion about how
it worked
one of the big mysteries was the
question
of it seems like things get more random
it seems like you put all the molecules
in a in in your room
in the corner of the room and they'll
all sort of escape from the corner and
they'll start bouncing around randomly
it seems like things get more random
over time
and there seems to be a principle that
things always get more random over time
that things that if you using entropy as
a measure of randomness that the
randomness always increases
now that's a little bit weird because i
mentioned actually i mentioned in my
my previous answer that one feature of
of microscopic physics is that every
process
is reversible so if you see if you have
a movie that shows two atoms colliding
with each other bouncing off going off
in a different direction
you can't tell if you ran that movie in
reverse
it would still be a perfectly valid
possible collision of atoms
you can't tell the difference between
the movie running forwards the movie
running backwards
but on the other hand uh but but that's
true for individual
collisions of atoms but on the other
hand if you saw a movie
in which all the air in this room
suddenly decided to go off into one
corner of the room
and the rest of the room was a vacuum
you would say that's an extremely
implausible
possible this is something which would
never happen right
so even though in principle it can
happen in principle
you can reverse all the momentum of all
the all the directions of all the atoms
and make them all arrange themselves in
one corner that never actually happens
in practice
okay so in the 1860s and so on started
to be
the idea of the so-called second law of
thermodynamics
which was the law that says that
basically
things tend to get more random that when
you have random emotional molecules
it gets it sort of spreads the
randomness it never
the randomness never sort of
spontaneously makes itself more
organized even though in principle it
could it just never happens in practice
and so and that has the consequence that
for example
heat never goes from a colder body to a
hotter body
if you have a thing one thing that's hot
one thing that's cold
the hot thing will make the cold thing
hotter but the
the you'll never get spontaneously
heat coming out of the cold body and
going into the hotter body so you'll
never get the
the two bodies will never diverge in
temperature they'll always come closer
in temperature
they'll always come to an equilibrium
where they're at the same temperature
so that's that's a feature of the second
order from dynamics that things tend to
get more random
rather than less rounds if those two if
you had you know one bar of metal that
was hot one bar metal it was cold
and the hotter one got hotter the colder
one got colder you would be sort of
organizing things in a way that never
seems to spontaneously happen
okay so back in the maybe 1870s
a guy called liberty boltzmann who was
very big in
in the whole entropy business thought
that he had proved
that entropy increases with time now
he kind of thought that he proved a
thing he called his h theorem
and what he proved is that if you just
look at these
collisions of molecules and you just say
does this quantity that he defined as as
as the spontaneous that represents
randomness does it increase with time
well he proved it does increase with
time but that's a bit of a whoops
because the laws of physics are
reversible so actually it turns out you
can just reverse his derivation
and show that just as it implies that
the entropy increases with time
so also the same derivation run in
reverse
shows that entropy decreases with time
well you know this is a a point
that you know you go through this whole
mathematical derivation and you get to
this really weird result
and uh i fond of a a particular
well-known book
about statistical physics the theory of
of large assemblies of atoms and so on
which has a whole whole chapter about
the second order thermodynamics and
explains the h theorem
and it explains the fact that when you
reverse it it goes the other way
and it ends the chapter this point is
often puzzling to the student
well the truth is it's been puzzling to
everybody for about a hundred years
um the reason it happens in the way that
boltzmann set things up
is he made a thing he called the
molecular chaos assumption
and that assumption basically said that
well he's kind of assuming that things
are random before atoms collide
but they're not random afterwards and so
that saying that random before
is creating something that is no longer
reversible so that's why
he kind of managed to prove his theorem
in both directions
okay so how does entropy actually work
um
it's been a very confusing story i think
i finally figured this out actually in
the 1990s
um what the actual story is um
i would say that one of the other
confounding confusions
is what happens with entropy and gravity
because
while normally things become more and
more disordered
uh you know that you tend to get with
ordinary gases and things like that
things just tend to sort of get um more
and more random
in the universe with gravity that's not
the case where you know gravity
pulls things together makes galaxies it
makes the central black holes of
galaxies
etc etc so that's a gal
gravity seems to have an anti-entropic
character
that's somewhat now understood in terms
of black hole entropy and so on
um and that wasn't back 40 years ago
i was very interested in that question
of how gravity manages to do
sort of the opposite of what the second
law of thermodynamics says
and perhaps it has something to do with
the fact that gravity is a long range
force perhaps it has something to do
with
some other issues with the second law of
thermodynamics and people weren't very
clear whether the second law of
thermodynamics was
a fact of physics or whether it was
something that was a piece of
essentially mathematics that you could
prove for anything
but the gravity case is important
because it shows you that pretty much
it's not a mathematical fact or at least
not one that is happens without a bunch
of assumptions
because there's a case where it doesn't
really apply
okay so how does the second law actually
work um
the the basic thing that's happening is
that
when you it's all a question of of how
do you
set up the initial condition for a
system
how do you set up all the molecules of
gas in a corner
how do you set them up somewhere else
versus how do you measure the results
and and the basic point is that if you
were to set up all the molecules of gas
in one corner
then they would it would they would they
would spread out but
they would spread out in some
complicated way but in principle you
could always reverse them back
and you could always find them going
back into that corner the problem is
when we actually measure the gas we're
not able to know
precisely the positions momentum and so
on of every single atom in the gas
so that process of going backwards of
reversing things and figuring out what
they came from
is not one we can readily do so
when the for purposes of our
observations
things will look kind of random because
we won't know that they came from that
simple thing
and and the way this works is a very
nice way of thinking about this in terms
of computation
so and this is going to get me into a
slippery slope of another topic which
i'm not going to go
deeply down here but um when you
uh do encryption so encryption is all
about
you know you are taking this file of
text
and you're encrypting it and that's
turning it into something that seems
random
and then only if you have the right key
can you go backwards
but it takes to go from without the
right key to go from that
you go from the text to the encrypted
form
and in principle you can always go
backwards from the encrypted form to the
unencrypted form
but in practice that's a lot of
computational work to do that
and that's what's happening in physical
systems with the law of entropy increase
the secondary thermodynamics
is the the process of
the uh evolution of the system is
essentially encrypting
that initial data so let's say you put
the molecules on one side of the box
one side of the room whatever that that
it is still the case that there's a
trace of that information
in the configuration of molecules much
later but it's encrypted there
and to to find out that you really came
from that
the molecules on one side of the room
you'd have to basically
run a decryption process and that's a
that decryption process is something
that is not
feasible for us to do when we're
actually observing molecules
um it's not something that we we don't
have the computational ability
to do that and it's all connected with
this phenomenon of computational
irreducibility that i've studied a lot
but that's that's basically the story
and so finally i think we understand
the second law of thermodynamics in
terms of things about computational
irreducibility
and the computational limitations of
observers like us
um but that's something that's only
fairly recently been understood and
that's kind of
my contribution i suppose to these
things is trying to understand that um
but that's that's that's roughly how it
works so
i'm sorry that was a little bit um uh
a little bit complicated here okay we
have a question here from
uh jackbound what are the scientifically
most
interesting places i have visited
well let's see there always are
what are some good tourist attractions
particle accelerators
gravitational wave detectors
radio telescopes yeah somewhat
um so particle accelerators
well there's fermilab which is um
about i never remember how big these are
you can you can look at them on
satellite pictures they're big it's a
big circular accelerator which
which accelerates uh protons and
antiprotons
uh to very very close to the speed of
light going around this giant ring
the ring is underground the ring is also
radioactive
you can't go and see it most of the time
um
but the um uh
it's it's particularly when fermilab is
shut down
um you can often see the particle
detectors and so on and they're pretty
cool
that's uh that's near chicago and
batavia illinois
um and that's uh that's a um
uh so particle accelerator that's a good
thing to see
the biggest particle accelerator in the
world is at cern
uh near the geneva airport um in
switzerland
um and uh the um
boy i just realized the utter confusion
of the fact that um
fermilab is near geneva illinois that's
really confusing
um but cern is geneva switzerland um
so that's a again not as much of a
tourist attraction as one might like
because once the particle accelerator is
in operation
the the whole tunnel that in which all
the magnets and things are is
radioactive and you can't go there
there was a time a few years ago when
cern had a kind of an open day
before they closed it up to start a new
experimental
run um when people could go and go in
the tunnel and see things but but that's
that's in the past now um
the other uh so another thing
is gravitational wave detectors uh in
the u.s there's one in louisiana one in
washington state
i've s
at least conceptually cool again you
can't actually
see sort of inside the kind of cavity of
the gravitational wave detector because
it's this thing that's measuring
distances to a tiny fraction of the
of the diameter of an atom it's
measuring the
weather gravitational waves which kind
of deform space time
and cause sort of everything to deform
in
in distance um come through it and a few
years ago it detected this merger of
black holes a third of the way across
the universe
by measuring gravitational radiation
that had come from them but that's a
that's another good science um science
thing
um i suppose the other uh
radio telescopes somewhat interesting
the vla i haven't been there for a long
long time that's the very large array
which is in socorro new mexico near
albuquerque
um and that's uh that's a place that
i'm afraid is is perhaps most famous for
having been in the movie contact
which shows these very elaborate um you
know it has a bunch of dishes that are
on a railroad track and they go up and
down
to have different distances between the
dishes to make different measurements
i have to say back when the contact
movie was made what must have been early
1990s i think um
i i knew the people who were
involved with the actual software for
operating radio telescope
and also people who were involved in
making the
the the uh the made for the movies
software for operating radio telescope
in the movie
and the software for operating rated
telescope in the movie was a great deal
more sophisticated
than the software for operating the
telescope as the actual telescope in
fact back in those days
it was um there was a spreadsheet
program called lotus 123 that was
popular at that time
and the actual software was mostly lotus
123 macros kind of like excel macros
today that was being used for the
telescope very very primitive compared
to what was in the movie i tried to
connect
those two groups together but i don't
know whether anything really happened
there
um but anyway that's another thing
another good
good place to see in terms of science
some
tourism is the science museums
there are different um i could give you
a whole critique of science museums but
um
uh you know in the u.s i would say the
exploratorium in san francisco is very
hands-on
science museum has a lot of very
interesting exhibits um the chicago
museum of science and industry
is um uh is is a
good uh sort of display of lots of kinds
of technology as well as science
um i think the um uh there are a lot of
other new york
new york hall of science liberty science
center in in um
uh those are a little bit more kind of
oriented towards
um uh things of interest to kids and
school groups and so on back
um if you look outside the u.s the
london science museum has a very
important collection
of exhibits unfortunately they often
don't have lots of them on display
because i think
over the years when when i was a kid i
was a very small kid
um the uh i lived in london
and i used to visit the science museum i
i am told i
insisted on going there almost every day
when i was like two or three years old
um so go figure what that um the result
of that
has been but um back in those days that
must have been 1962 or three or so
they had just opened their first
hands-on exhibits
but now it's all hands-on exhibits but
most of what there was there at that
time
was um sort of the artifacts of the
history of science
um from um uh mostly from from england
around the world
the science museum has a has a very
impressive collection
of um of kind of important historical
scientific artifacts
um i think uh somewhat to my amusement
my uh
my my grandfather's my grandfather had a
bicycle
which came from somewhere was some made
it was a
chainless bicycle it had some kind of
gearing cogging type thing
not that he constructed he just bought
it as a consumer um
but he lent it to somebody sometime in
the 1950s and somehow
he never got it back but it was next
spotted
on display in the science museum at
least when i was last at the science
museum it was still on display in the
bicycle section of the science museum
and um the uh um
uh so so that's a a uh a curious
um uh uh kind of a
curious um uh thing but but this the
london science museum has has some
pretty good historical artifacts um
the munich science museum also has good
historical artifacts
berlin um uh has a good science museum
with that
i'm giving you a giant list of science
museums here um
but uh um those are
those are often good sort of um uh
collection points
for these things i of course have to
give a pitch
for the national museum of mathematics
that i happen to be on the board of
um that's in new york city in the u.s
that is not so much a a museum of
of mathematical notable mathematical
artifacts
as a museum of sort of hands-on
mathematics actually we're just
working on on creating a gallery
of uh the history of mathematics in fact
you can find a website that is just now
live or that hasn't really been
advertised yet
that we've been building uh for the
museum
that um is kind of a a collection of the
notable historical
um artifacts of mathematics um from
babylonian times on uh maybe maybe one
of these live streams i can i can go
through some of
what's there it's it's been an
interesting process trying to track down
kind of the the significant artifacts in
the history of mathematics
am i forgetting some big um uh
place where there are um notable
exhibits i don't know it's um um
probably i am i'm sorry to anybody who
is uh involved with the museum that i
that i should have mentioned and didn't
um but that's a few a few things
ah let's see
question here
um
boy there's some technical questions
here
ah all right i'll try
one from james craig here um
i mentioned virtual photons uh
i mean i'm going to just address this a
little bit the question is how long does
it take
how long does a virtual photon live
before it converts into a pair of
particles
okay here's the situation an ordinary
photon
has zero rest mass an ordinary photon
can exist forever you know we are
regularly
seeing photons that have existed since
very close to the beginning of the
universe
when we look out into the sky and we see
the cosmic microarray background
those are photons that last interacted
maybe a hundred thousand years after the
beginning of the universe and they've
been just
traveling freely for all that time
and when we observe one of them with one
of our detectors
or conceptually when we see it in our
eyes although we can't see microwaves
with our eyes
but um then that whole long journey of
14 billion years
that the photon has been on comes to an
end the photon is absorbed it's gone
um but photons can live forever and um
uh by the way for a photon because of
the way relativity works
for the photon because it's traveling at
the speed of light no time has passed
since the beginning of the universe so
if we were
if it was um if there was kind of an
intelligence that was
all existed in the form of photons then
it's like universe starts and next thing
you know
you're being absorbed by something else
and there's all that 14 billion years
has just delighted into no time at all
for the for the for the photon
but any case an ordinary photon lives
forever
okay one of the features of quantum
mechanics
is that you can um
even though a photon is supposed to have
zero mass almost everything that you
think might be true
can not be true if
you wait only a very short time so
photons even though they normally have
zero mass if you have a photon
and you're only it's only living
for 10 to the minus 20 seconds let's say
then it can have a then it can have a
mass for 10 to the minus 20 seconds
that's a consequence of the energy time
uncertainty principle
in quantum mechanics that there's an
uncertainty in the mass
you you think it's supposed to be zero
but actually there's an uncertainty in
the mass that can last for a very short
time
in in our theory of physics that has to
do with
uh in the multi-way graph that
represents all possible histories
it represents a kind of what we call a
branch pair
that can exist for a short time before
it merges
um and those branch pairs represent kind
of possible histories of the universe
rather than
features of particles let me not let me
not confuse with that now
but what happens in sort of standard
quantum field theory
is that a particle can exist
there's this uncertainty of its mass
uncertainty of its energy
and if you wait if you if you're looking
at it over a sufficiently short period
of time
you can be off from what it's supposed
to be so a virtual
photon um can live
for an amount of time if you want it to
have mass m
then it's uh let's see it's
um uh h-bar planck's constant divided by
m
is so am i getting the units right
no it's uh planck's constant divided by
m times c
squared so it's um uh
it's it's it's an amount of time that is
the if if it has a certain energy then
it is
well planck's constant is a sort of
quantum constant it's equal to 10 to the
minus 34
joule seconds um but it is this very
tiny constant but if you
it's that determines essentially the
amount of time
that a thing of a given energy a thing
with a sort of off
its usual mass energy relation
can exist and so that's basically what
determines the the lifetime of a virtual
photon
is what its effective mass is the larger
the effective mass
the the smaller the effective lifetime
okay let me see um
oh boy okay there's so many interesting
questions
wow
um the question from vijay
why do humans have unique fingerprints
iris patterns
um and other creatures
uh have similar kinds of uniqueness
yeah i mean even so
so to some extent there is a program
that specifies how to build
a creature that program is its genome
its dna sequence
and that dna sequence says how to
construct
the proteins which combine together to
make everything else which combine
together which combine together
to eventually make a human but for
example if you have identical twins
identical twins have exactly the same
dna
almost exactly the same dna for for
practical purposes the same dna
um and yet identical twins don't
typically have the exact same
fingerprints
often their fingerprints are similar but
they're not exactly the same
so the question is how does it come to
be the case that there are things where
even though you have the same program
you end up with slightly different let's
say fingerprints
slightly different patterns of um cells
on on well the the iris of your eye
features the retina of your eye uh the
the
the um the kind of the foldings of
brains are usually very
uh very specific ears can often be quite
specific
and so on well the answer tends to be
that when the organism is being grown
the um there are certain things which
are essentially physical processes there
are some things that are determined
by the genetic program they're actually
determined by the ways that
the biological molecules move around
that are specified by that program
but there are other things where you're
more or less just stirring some
some fluid up and it's it's kind of the
randomness that comes from
let's say fluid turbulence when you when
you stir a fluid
at high speed you'll get sort of all
kinds of random patterns
the exact origins of that are a little
bit not completely understood
but it's a it's a physical phenomenon
it's a phenomenon that doesn't have to
do with it's not
specified by the kind of genetic
structure of the
of the system so so these things like
fingerprints
come about because of random because of
physical effects
that are just a little bit different you
know in the in the two identical twins
you know one of them was hanging out
uh you know on on one side one of them
the other side and
maybe the the fluid flow rate was
slightly higher on one side than on the
other side
and so when the folding happened that
caused the fingerprints come from
various kinds of folding processes when
those folding processes were happening
um the the rate of folding was a little
bit higher on this side than on that
side
and so the fingerprint ends up being
different so it's kind of the
the interaction of physical uh random
physical effects
with what is otherwise kind of a genetic
program that leads to these kinds of
random features random differences
between uh even identical twin organisms
um and of course once you look at
different organisms which have different
genomes
certain things can start to be much more
different so for example if you look at
the the you know colors of irises of
eyes there's blue and there's brown and
there's a few other colors too
and those are those are determined
actually we kind of know
the genetics of blue and brown eyes and
so on
those are determined by very specific
places in the genetic
program this determines the color but
the the uh
the arrangement of of of actual material
there
is something that more comes from the
physical process and is not determined
by the
by the genetic um
by the genetic structure so
maybe one more question here and then i
should go
it's a question from androculus
if you could go back in time and um
i'm gonna i'm actually gonna answer two
questions here
let me answer one before this one
question from was from adam
what is your favorite unsolved problem
well depends on solve problem in what in
physics
i'll give you fundamental theory of
physics which
i am uh i'm working on
we're making great progress i think that
one we're going to be able to check off
as
as not being an unsolved problem i think
that um there are uh
there are many questions about um uh if
we ask very well-defined questions like
mathematical problems when you say
unsolved problem
i mean there are many many problems in
science i could talk about a bunch of
them
but in mathematics what's particularly
fun
is problems that people tried to solve
two thousand years ago
and they didn't figure it out and we
still don't know the answer
so one of those is um uh are there an
infinite number of twin primes
uh euclid for example third century bc
300 bc roughly um showed gave a
mathematical proof
that prime numbers you know two three
five
seven uh 11
13 etc etc etc that the sequence of
prime numbers
numbers which are divisible only by
themselves in one
that sequence of prime numbers goes on
forever but twin primes like 11 and 13
which are separated by two
nobody knows even today whether they're
an infinite number of twin primes
um euclid also wondered about actually
pythagoras wondered
about whether there are um odd
perfect numbers numbers whose that are
equal to the essentially the sum of
their divisors
and we still don't know the answer we
don't know any example of an odd perfect
number
but we haven't shown that they can't
exist so those have been
you know those are like 20 2 400 years
and counting
problems that people haven't solved
there are problems
that i'm personally very interested in
well there are problems about
um uh the representation of meaning
in um and uh let me not go down these
these paths that they're a lot of
interesting unsolved science problems
ask me about them another time here
um but there was a there was more of a
curiosity question here if i
if if i could go back in time and help a
legendary scientist solve a problem who
and what would it be
humph
you know these days
because i've been working on the
fundamental theory of physics i think
albert einstein would be my choice
because after he invented what is now
our current theory of gravity
general relativity in 1915 he was
pretty certain that he hadn't gotten to
the bottom of how things like that work
and he was pretty certain at that time
quantum mechanics was being invented
and he was pretty certain that it would
turn out
that for example space and time will be
discrete
rather than continuous but he said
you know people have been sending me
versions of he said this many times over
the course of his life
that you know almost certainly the
theory that he had in 1915 wasn't the
full story
but to get the full story you would
think about space and time as being
discrete
but the tools that um
would be necessary to understand that
did not exist he said
well we now have them and
it would have been um it would be cool
to um
uh to kind of um uh you know
old albert would have been able to get a
lot further if he'd had the tools we
have today although
in his day ideas about computation and
so on just didn't exist
i suppose another person i would i would
find it fun
uh gottfried leibniz who lived in the um
late 1600s
was one of the inventors of calculus was
a person who was very much
interested in kind of making precise
things that we would just talk about in
in a
human language like english or german or
latin or whatever
um and he tried hard to make
kind of a he had this idea
of sort of making um something like a
computer
which would even understand which would
be able to for example
decide legal cases be able to answer
questions be able
to do things like this he tried to start
collecting knowledge by by collecting
books and things like this
he tried to start making a computer i
saw the one he made it's made of brass
and it is a thing where you turn you
know turn cogs
and it can do some simple arithmetic
well
he was really close to thinking about
what we now think of as universal
computation things like turing machines
things sort of abstract theories of
computation but he didn't quite get it
and it would be really cool to have uh
seeded something back in the 1600s
because the ideas of computation
the ideas of things like turing machines
are not
that difficult a lot of the ideas i've
worked on about simple programs like
cellular automata
they could have been done by the
babylonians and you know
four thousand years ago there's nothing
conceptually difficult about them
it's just nobody thought they were
interesting and i think it would be fun
to go back and seed leibniz with a
touring machine
actually leibniz wrote a lot of stuff in
his life
he has quite big archive of all the
things he wrote
and actually kurt gerdel famous logician
um uh who was a little bit strange
uh in in many ways um
had this belief that leibniz had
discovered some great truth
but the truth had been suppressed in
history
and so i was very curious a number of
years ago i went to look at the leibniz
archive and i was like going through and
looking
looking through it and i wondered could
it have been the case that leibniz
actually invented something like a
turing machine
in the 1600s but people just didn't have
the right context to understand it i
don't think he did
but he could have done and had he done
that
one of the things that would have
happened is computation would have
existed before calculus
and the history of existing mathematics
and science
has been very dominated by the
cleverness of calculus
and the cleverness of derivatives and
integrals and things like that
and it took until kind of efforts like
mine in the in the 1990s and 1980s and
1990s and so on
to really establish computation as
a a good method for making models of
things
um making sort of fundamental models of
things but actually the history could
have been different
leibniz could have invented computation
back in the 1600s before he invented
calculus
and had he done that the history of
science would have been completely
different and the history of technology
probably as well
so that would have been a nice sort of
pivot point
to um uh to change the history of
history of science
i think also i've recently been studying
quite a bit
uh euclid's work euclid was the person
who sort of axiomatized gave the first
sort of systematic
logical treatment of geometry that that
has survived at least
from around 300 bc um and uh
he made certain assumptions about how
the geometrical world works
like the assumption that space is
continuous doesn't is
not made of discrete things like like
water is made of discrete molecules
and i think he's wrong i think that
there are really sort of atoms of space
and it would be super interesting to
sort of go back to euclid and say
gosh you know what if you um
uh you kind of um what if you set up
your geometry
with atoms of space rather than spaces
continuous
what then follows and again very
different history of science would
develop
i mean i think one topic maybe i'll
maybe i'll do this another
another time um it um
uh is um let's talk a little bit about
the way that thinking about science has
changed over the years i mean i
i've always thought it's a fun exercise
to imagine you go
you go back to some scientist
technologist of old
and you have a laptop a modern laptop
and you show it to them
and the question is what on earth do
they think it is
and i think it's very very interesting
at different times in history
maybe i'll talk about this another time
to think about what the answer would be
i think
i think i was thinking about pythagoras
for example
so pythagoras had all kinds of theories
about souls and so on and so on and so
on
and i think the um i kind of think
that pythagoras would have had the
theory
that the laptop is a thing that contains
disembodied souls
and in that he's not completely wrong
the
in the sense that sort of the the idea
of a sort of disembodied soul a thing
that has some kind of thought-like
process
but isn't manifest in something like a
brain
is kind of what's going on on a computer
and i i can just sort of imagine the
conversation with pythagoras who i'm
sure was a
quite strange fellow he had a lot of
strange things but
but anyway he he ran a cult uh
eventually in southern italy
um that had a lot of a lot of weird
beliefs but anyway never mind that
um he um he uh um
i i just sort of imagined this question
of okay
the com you know this thing is full of
disembodied human souls
but whose souls are they well in some
sense they're the souls of the
programmers
who created this thing it's a it's a you
know it's kind of a weird story
of of of where you can take kind of the
um
and that will become more even more of a
story as we get sort of better ai
and better ability to replicate what uh
sort of uh
all kinds of things that us humans do um
and uh at some point it's like well that
is a disembodied
sort of soul-like thing that is now
fixed in the computer
anyway maybe another time we can talk
about some uh sort of
the view of modern technology that
people at different
kinds times in history might have had i
think it's somewhat revealing
um as a way to kind of contextualize
what we now
understand and what was easy to
understand and what
requires whole stacks of modern
knowledge
to be able to understand and what some
sort of contextualizes our current
knowledge
and gives us a certain degree of
humility about
how we will view the knowledge that we
have today
from the future um and i certainly know
in the things that i've been working on
a lot of things that i'm now figuring
out it's like gosh how could i have been
so stupid 40 years ago when i was last
thinking about this
you know why did i not see the things
that i can now see
and that has to do with a sort of whole
stack of context
of ways of thinking about things that i
didn't have back in the past
um
oh boy interesting question sir i'm i'm
so tempted but i really need to go off
and do something else uh
uh vook here is asking what's the oldest
known and unknown civilization which had
the notion of the universe
and mathematics i think the civilization
that really is the winner in terms of
what we know about what they think is
the babylonians
because they had this feature that they
recorded
all kinds of things on clay tablets and
the clay tablets
survived other civilizations maybe they
used wood maybe they used something else
maybe they weren't as into keeping
records as the babylonians
um but the babylonians very definitely
they kept diaries astronomical diaries
for 700 years
every night they would record the state
of the sky they would record the weather
it would record the height of the river
they would record the price of grain and
we have i think one or two percent of
those diaries still exists
um and uh so we can kind of know what
they said but
but it's really interesting what the
babylonians thought was sort of
uh a feature of the universe they had
theories about the universe maybe we
don't know quite all
they were but like for example one thing
i i just find is an interesting sort of
contextualization is there are certain
aspects of the universe that are very
regular
the planets they knew went went in
regular cycles
and they knew they were sort of going in
circles and things like this
um and so that was a very regular thing
question is what's regular what's not
regular
so there's a map of the world from
babylonian times
and the map of the world is regular that
is the babylonians you know they'd seen
the planets going around and they
thought
well gosh you know the the pattern of
land
on the earth must somehow have that same
kind of regularity
so when they try to draw a map of the
earth it has a very regular
form and that's certainly an interesting
thing of what's
uh what's kind of a a determined
sort of by what what shows evidence of
its simplicity
and what does not and then there's well
there's lots to say about that
very interesting question all right i
need to uh
need to go and um uh well thanks for all
those interesting questions
and i look forward to uh to continue in
this next week
and i'd be happy if people are
interested to
talk a little bit about that sort of uh
um
i don't know what if history types of
questions
all right thanks very much and uh
bye for now